so in just the same way as I did with
number 11 I'm gonna look at this and
with it all what that's code for is two
different things at the same time
because that position are ladies and we
don't want asked to write this to table
every single time we're like let's just
agree that this is one of me however
when you got that you can't really do a
collection of like terms that can happen
because the brackets are in the way so
therefore we have to get really active a
phone so it's just normal algebra and
then we consider like I'm going to step
in here so what I break up I into 2 i'm
going to say okay sometimes young as
though there is your sex this top action
unchanged okay my question is when is
the active of X just X it is is X is fun
right in this case there's no
discontinuities because I'm not dividing
by anything like I was over here so in
fact you can put in any Mary value of x
that you like and you'll never run into
problems like we use perfume okay so
therefore i can actually include the
battery there I could have included kid
rivers on so it was a little time yet
little is yet group that stuff in your
urine 01 oh well so listen to this
little we've seen so because I'm 0 is
neither positive nor negative if you
follow the plus sign or a minus island
it doesn't matter so it's actually true
for both at the same time which is kind
of strange um it's a little we bow to
say I that something is is two different
things even for the same values so by
convention we only put it on one because
it's just weird DNA I'm both at the same
time yet so yeah that's right we are we
have my quantum superposition by which
it just to give you a quick right to an
adult now the animators jump thank you
for this but i'll totally we negative x
butters if x is messenger
okay so I just so separated it into
jihad and now I can actually simplify
tricky our X of X under were that easy
and again that has a domain attached to
it whereas my dimension x is equal to
something else in this degree that ok so
now I'm really doing Jordan picks on top
so lucky where you click exit yeah so
this is another chain too young to let
me just now and you know something it's
a bit weird because I can actually do
this what is it doesn't actually matter
because the x equals 0 it's not a
positive or negative so if you actually
sit on either of these things another
way you can figure out is like this the
answer values newer should i define an
added plus zero or shine planet as my
spirit and in truth I don't care like
Idaho's is still 0 okay so therefore if
I which you know usually I have to
decide which branch I mean but 0 is that
we especially that doesn't care which
one you decide you don't end up the same
value so for that reason you can put it
on either I see it more frequently on
this one but it literally doesn't matter
so I'm just going to choose one okay
children yeah so again just like before
what I have to think about is this is
going piecemeal function so it's one
function y equals something but
sometimes its sequel addition sometimes
speak with that ok so again I'll get
from left to right so the negative
values of x I have to draw y equal 0
well that's the x-axis isn't it why does
your ease the x-axis so therefore should
have an Arras up here therefore on the
left hand side I'm just going to draw
why
equal 0 that's it y equal 0 if X is less
than zero so visual by a negative values
of x cos let the x-axis natural the
wires so that's how two grandsons there
is a all right one time one time switch
over I turn into the new Graham 2x so 2x
is a bit steep so I'm going to draw
awkward like that that's y equals 2x and
that's it if I wouldn't be a little more
precise about it I would say you know
however you are you doing I have a point
about what happens when you change from
one to the other that's that matter
sometimes it takes that's done right
because what it looks continuous others
it is continuous it doesn't have a break
or anything like that like that but if
you want to be like really either
certain about it just got a full circle
in it because at X equal 0 I do have a
value I'm like oh they're so little
little point there is none of these
white on yeah people yo people idea is
it on it is calling on a critical point
um so the word the phrase critical point
is used in a variety of different
contexts and unfortunately I seen it
needs lots of different times to mean
different things so some people call
that a critical point and other people
will call a critical point what we plan
to do like our text I'll just finish it
so things like on that later on we're
going to learn about calculor to let a
stationary point critical is like as a
word in English just may be important
right and like well that's pretty
important to that where it turns around
a lot of people will say that poisonous
information which they turn around but
they kind of like have a bit of a bit
some people call back their critical one
is like what is it right so therefore I
am I don't tend to call it that because
it's 200 years yeah
like depends a lot of teeth twice on
yeah yeah find a critical pointed at you
could plot from there yes that's right
so in other words what they're saying is
okay totally where we chose switches
over from one to the other that's the
important point and then in digital to
level to the right and sometimes you
grab my bobbin one important point
sometimes going to change multiple times
we make it to something better with that
morning okay yeah that's like so I'm
like I said I've got fond of the word
because there is not much agreement as
to what it means among textbooks on
teachers etc so I just trying to be
clear so how do you feel about that
question all right now I work I won't
practice however the second part of it
let me change the sign are the
operations rather between them and you
can see it would carry on in much the
same way except that visibly my designs
which would mean X minus X that's going
to become zero we're just loop it looks
it thats exactly racks up and here minus
X minus X would be emergency ex okay so
if I was drawing dispersion of the graph
there are the flipping is actually very
careful look at the kind of thing that
you've got and these my color where is
this graph this new one that I've
adjusted where is it y equal zero in
what do mean that is great ass again
yeah but suicide is on Tori that's kind
over there and where is y equals minus
2x well it x is less than zero now what
does that look like this is minus 2x
isn't it let me know so it's actually
eclipse corazon your weight not which is
literally waited but that's what the
advertisement okay